هنا يقبع الثاني اكبر اقتصادات العالم اذا
ما قلنا اضخمها في عام 2030 ومن شانغهاي
الشريان الاقتصادي صدرت قوانين لم تكن في
حسبان الشركات الاجنبيه ومع صدد اقرارها
ينضب قلق المستثمرين صحيفه وولد الامريكيه
كشفت عن الصندوق الاسود الذي تعكف الصين
على تخبئه معلوماتها السريه داخله بعيدا
عن اعين الغرب حيث قيدت بكين الوصول
الخارجيه الى قواعد البيانات المختلفه
التي تشمل معلومات تسجيل الشركات وبراءات
الاختراع وغيرها من الوثائق والاحصائيات
فالرئيس الصيني اكد ان التصدي لتهديدات
الغربيين اولى من استقبال استثماراتهم
فالامن القومي يشغل باله منذ زمن ليس
ببعيد وبحسب التقرير لا تجديد اشتراكات
لعديد من الكيانات والمراكز الاجنبيه في
شركه ويند الص لما وصفتها بقضايا امتثال
وكانت من بين الشركات المستهدفه مجموعه
منزوا
الامريكيه ودولويت للاستشارات الماليه في
بريطانيا فكل واحده منها تعرضت اما
الاستجواب موظفيها في شنغهاي ومداهمات
اعتقال او لتعليق عمليات او حتى لفرض
غرامات وصلت احداها لواحد وثلاثين مليون
دولار
اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات